[Music]
we're in this beautiful beautiful garden
that's been here for
several hundred years the big change
over the last four years has been
moving away from the use of chemicals
and um
to a completely sort of rewilding
approach
the plants
seem to be flourishing with that
there's far more insects the number of
species of moths has gone up threefold i
think
our bees are producing wonderful honey
and the change in terms of biodiversity
has been extraordinary
[Music]
[Music]
in places like kenya and nigeria
it's not just
it makes for nice gardens it's life and
death because biodiversity the
chain of life
from the smallest to the largest is what
enables farming to happen is what
enables crops to grow
climate change and loss of biodiversity
are existential threats
to a huge chunk of humanity and yet the
political leaders haven't taken the bold
action necessary why do you think that's
happened we have failed to listen
to the voice of creation
[Music]
we've been selfish in the global north
with
the way we operate uh particularly in
industry and in personal consumption
it's a fundamental disconnection with
nature and a sort of sense that it's a
thing a resource
rather than
something that needs to be tended and
cared for
[Music]
i think what the earth is saying and
we've seen that especially over the last
couple of years
it's an agonized cry of pain
i can't breathe
and the problem is if the earth can't
breathe
we can't breathe
and the churches have been part of this
neglect of creation almost an
unconscious war with creation
[Music]
we believe in transformation and
conversion rather than isolation and
exclusion
a few years ago the church of england
set up and now chairs
a global coalition of investors with
over 10 trillion dollars of investments
the aim of initiative is to have a clear
pathway
towards net zero for companies
and we've disinvested from coal
companies because it can't be done with
them
and by 2023
any company that is not
objectively audited as moving in the
right direction at a rapid pace
we will disinvest
[Music]
[Applause]
god offers forgiveness
and that should be the same for us where
companies change
where there is a genuine commitment to
zero carbon
where there is repentance of the
personal immorality of the way we behave
expressed at a corporate and
governmental level as well as
individually
then forgiveness is absolutely right
[Music]